- First of all, you got to work on your stamina.
- Chuck, I would destroy you.
Even before you discovered carbs.
Trust the process. Trust the process. Trust the—
- [Modern announcer:] Welcome to the
arena outside of space and time,
where we play one-on-one, win by two.
On one side, we have 2021's Joel Embiid.
- All-in. Ah!
Man, I had good cards!
- [Old-school announcer:] Versus 1991 Charles Barkley.
The battle of the tough guys.
- Say no more. I get it. I watch cartoons.
- Oh, you look mad as hell. Did I spit on your kid?
- [Modern announcer:] Embiid clearing out some space!
Joel scores. It's a pump fake for me, fam.
- Phila? What the hell happened to Delphia?
- Play me. I need to prove to future you that I am better.
- Man, get off me, soft serve Olajuwon.
- [Old-school announcer:] Barkley is unmovable.
- [Modern announcer:] He takes a tough fadeaway.
- [Old-school announcer:] And Chuck proves that
you can't measure heart in inches.
- Hey Robot Marv Albert, can I put money on this game?
- [Modern announcer:] Barkley drives...he misses...
gets his own rebound...scores.
Oh, man, this is like seeing old photos of your dad.
And The Process processed his ass!
- Charles, look what white people from the internet taught me.
- What the hell is the internet? Don't y'all have guards?
- Not really.
- My God, this guy's less of a role model than me.
Don't look! Don't look!
- [Old-school announcer:] Barkley is just relentless right now.
- 'Scuse me.
- [Modern announcer:] He slams it home!
- Too weak.
- [Old-school announcer:] The Round Mound is light on his feet.
- It's too easy.
- Now let's see how these two do in Playoff Atmosphere!
- Ow! Come on, man.
- Ah, my knee!
- [Old-school announcer:] They don't have what it takes.
Turn it off!
- [Modern announcer:] And Embiid can beat
America's Uncle right now.
- No man can back me down.
- I am not a man; I am a TROLL! Hahahahaha!
- Oh no, he's starting to play like a big man.
- [Modern announcer:] And Joel wins! Proving he could beat
at least one-third of the guys in the Capitol One ads.
- Charles, you taught me how to be a big man.
Do you remember?
- Why do you think I've been so hard on you?
- I love you, Charles Barkley.
- I love you, Joel Embiid.
- [sobbing]
- This is so fun.
I'm definitely subscribing for more.
- Oh God, we're on the kiss cam.
[Crowd chanting "kiss, kiss"]
I guess we should just get it over with?
- I, uh, don't think of you that way?
- [PA announcer:] OK, next couple!
- You know, they should do MJ vs. LeBron next.
- I should have taken my brother.